vamos a hacer unos cuantos problemas que
traigan juntos los conceptos que
aprendimos en los últimos vídeos así que
digamos que tenemos la siguiente
desigualdad que es 4 x + 3 es menor que
menos 1 ok
tenemos 4 x 3 es menor que menos 1 y lo
primero que se me ocurre para ir
encontrando todas las x que satisfacen
esta desigualdad eso es lo que queremos
realmente hacer pues es primero quitar
este 3 que me está estorbando verdad y
cómo lo quitamos pues qué tal si
restamos 3 de ambos lados que y restamos
3 de ambos lados desigualdad de esta
desigualdad y al final de cuentas cuando
uno resta números de una desigualdad
pues no pasa nada con él con el signo de
la desigualdad se queda igual entonces
estos se cancelan y simplemente de este
lado me queda 4x que es menor que menos
uno menos tres que es menos cuatro muy
bien
entonces ahora para quitarme este 4 que
me está estorbando de mi x pues puedo
dividir entre 4 dividimos ambos lados
entre 4 y aquí como dividimos entre un
número positivo recordemos que la
desigualdad sólo se cambia de sentido
cuando multiplicamos o dividimos por un
número negativo por ejemplo por si
multiplicas por menos uno menos un medio
menos 10 qué sé yo pero aquí estamos
dividiendo entre un número positivo que
es 4 así que no pasa nada
no le afecten nada y esto me dice que
queda x porque estos se cancelan es
menor que menos 4 entre 4 que es menos 1
y esto ya es nuestro conjunto solución
ahora que si lo quieres ver en términos
de intervalos pues partimos de al menos
1 y no lo incluimos verdad aquí no nos
está diciendo que lo incluyamos y nos
vamos para abajo todo para abajo hasta
llegar al menos infinito ok
llegamos a menos infinito y esta es
nuestra notación verdad el paréntesis
significa que no estamos incluyendo a
menos 1 y por supuesto al menos infinito
no lo podemos incluir porque no es un
número entonces esta es nuestra solución
en en términos de intervalos vamos a ver
otro ejemplo un poco más difícil digamos
que tengo 5 x más grande que 8 x más 27
más 27 entonces nuevamente queremos de
alguna forma ir despejando la x entonces
qué tal si este 8x lo pasamos del otro
lado restando es decir qué pasaría si yo
restó 8 x de ambos lados
si yo restó 8 x de ambos lados entonces
lo que me queda de este lado son 5 x 8 x
que son menos 3 x y de este lado pues
estos se cancelan y me queda aquí el 27
este 27 de aquí ahora la desigualdad
realmente tampoco cambia porque no
estamos multiplicando o dividiendo
verdad simplemente por restamos un
número y eso no afecta en nada y
entonces se queda el el signo mayor que
ahora bien queremos despejar la x
nuevamente pues que podemos hacer
dividir todo entre menos 3 y si
dividimos todo entre menos 3 y ahora si
notemos que estamos dividiendo entre un
número negativo en este caso si se
invierte la desigualdad ok entonces
tenemos menos 3x dividido entre menos 3
va a estar relacionado ahorita vemos
como con 27 entre menos 3 y como dijimos
que dividimos entre un número negativo
este mayor que pues ya no va a ser mayor
que ahora se invierte se voltea verdad
se invierte y ahora es un menor que
realmente la forma en que yo me acuerdo
de qué significan estos símbolos es que
por ejemplo la parte que está más
abierta digamos esta apertura es el que
indica al número más grande no puede ser
no sé pensar como que esta es la mayor
altura que hay en este en este simbólico
y acá está la menor altura verdad es
pero eso no te confunde la forma en que
yo me acuerdo y espero te sirva pero
bueno si seguimos esto
esto se cancela y me queda que x es más
chico que 27 / menos 3 que eso no es
otra cosa más que menos 9 ok entonces
nuevamente si uno quisiera expresar lo
en términos de intervalos pues tengo
menos 9 que no lo incluyo por eso pongo
el paréntesis y me voy hacia abajo hasta
menos infinito muy bien
vamos a divertirnos un poco con la línea
real qué pasa si yo quiero graficar mi
resultado pues por ejemplo podemos
pensar que quedan de al menos 9 sacan
del -8 a candle menos 10 y lo que dice
es tomate todos los más chicos que menos
9 pero a menos 9 no lo incluya nos
ponemos una bolita y nos tomamos todos
los más chicos que menos 9 y ponemos la
bolita sin rellenar porque no lo estamos
incluyendo verdad muy bien muy bien
hasta ahí vamos ahora hacer un ejemplo
un poco más complicado un poco más
enredado muy bien por ejemplo este que
tengo aquí que es 8 x menos 5 veces 4 x
+ 1
mayor o igual que menos uno más dos
veces 4x menos 3
muy bien entonces yo sé que esto puede
parecer aterrador que quizás ya te ya te
dio miedo pero realmente no es muy
distinto a los que hemos hecho
anteriormente solo hay que simplificar
estas expresiones y verás que llegamos a
cosas muy similares entonces eso es lo
que vamos a hacer vamos a distribuir
estos productos y tenemos aquí 8x y
quién es menos 5 x 4 x eso es menos 20 x
y ahora menos 5 por 1 es menos 5 esta
desigualdad pues realmente no estamos
haciendo nada más que simplificar así
que se queda igual y esto es mayor o
igual que menos 1 y ahora hacemos 2 x 4
x son 8 x y 2 x menos 3 es menos 6 ok
muy bien entonces esto realmente ya es
mucho más amigable lo que tenemos que
hacer pues poder por ejemplo podemos
agrupar estos términos del lado
izquierdo cuánto será 8x menos 20 x pues
eso en realidad es menos 12 x verdad
hacemos la resta y le dejamos el signo
del más grande
entonces esto es 12 x el menos 5 se
queda igual y esto es mayor o igual y
aquí que es lo que podemos hacer podemos
agrupar los términos constantes y
tenemos menos uno menos seis es menos 7
al cual le estamos sumando 8x muy bien
muy bien entonces si queremos dejar las
x todas del lado izquierdo pues lo que
nos conviene de restar 8x de ambos lados
verdad para que aquí se cancele entonces
restamos 8x de este lado y restamos 8x
de este lado que es lo que me queda del
lado izquierdo pues menos 12 x menos 8 x
son menos 20 x
este menos 5 se queda igual el signo
realmente no cambia sólo estamos
restando así que esto va a ser mayor o
igual que menos 7 y estos se cancelan
muy bien muy bien entonces para seguir
despejando la equis
ahora vamos a sumar 5 de ambos lados
para quitar este 5 de aquí que nos está
estorbando entonces si sumamos 5 de
ambos lados esto se cancela esto me
queda menos 20 x menos 20 x que es mayor
o igual es mayor o igual que quién es
esta suma menos 75 es menos 2 menos 75
es menos 2 muy bien ahora sí vamos a
dividir todo entre menos 20 para que la
x quede solita como nos gusta sin
embargo sin embargo qué es lo que
sabemos que si dividimos entre un número
negativo tenemos que invertir la
desigualdad entonces tenemos menos 20 x
sobre menos 20 aquí ahorita digo que
pasa y esto es menos 2
entre -20 y la desigualdad se tiene que
cambiar se tiene que cambiar de mayor o
igual a menor o igual entonces esto ya
se cancela y me queda x menor o igual
que menos entre menos es más y 2 entre
20 eso son 1 sobre 10 es un décimo en
términos de notaciones de intervalos
pues empezamos en un décimo y éste si lo
incluimos por eso ponemos este tipo de
límite verdad y nos vamos hacia abajo
hasta el menos infinito abierto muy bien
ya nada más por diversión vamos a ver
qué pasa si lo grafica mos por ejemplo
aquí andará el 0 por acá andará el 1 y
quizás aquí ande el 11º el 11º y me dice
tómate el 11º y éste incluye lo entonces
rellenamos el circulito y tomate todos
los que son más chicos que él y puedes
intentarlo elige cualquier número más
chiquito que un décimo y verás que
satisface la desigualdad